[Music]  when shivani's first job might surprise  you she's revealing 17 things you never  knew about her in the April 2017 issue  of Marie Claire I'm so having so much  fun these are all the highlights she  made her first dollar working at Dairy  Queen if she wasn't a singer-songwriter  she thinks that she'd be a makeup artist  I just always loved to be creative she  still hasn't had a moment where she felt  like she'd made it quote I'm always  trying to make it in so many different  ways this is a journey yeah last thing  she binge-watched was Beverly Hills  90210 she credits her passion for  getting her where she is today adding my  heart drives me the song that makes her  cry is this one off her latest salvo I  don't know what but i think is closer  remember for the first time  the hated you  you and if she could have any superhero  power she'd take endless energy  you